professor salt is good morning why well
it's a pleasure to have this opportunity
to speak to you about your about your
book why they do it let me start with
asking you how is it that you came upon
deciding to write a book about the
perspectives and the backgrounds and the
thinking of white-collar criminals oh
I'm a financial economist by training
and this book actually began all the way
back when I was a graduate student
working on large empirical data set like
most graduate students are doing up at
3:00 in the morning and I came across a
show called MSNBC lockup
kind of thing you watch at 3:00 in the
morning a cross between a reality TV
show and a documentary and on the show
they had a crew going to various prisons
and they were interviewing a convicted
felon
most of which were convicted for violent
offenses murder assault rape and I was
watching the show and I started to think
about the kinds of people that I wonder
and think about the the people who are
in the titans of industry finance that
we saw the cover of fortune speaking at
commencement donating generously and
wondering what happened to these guys
these people that I like many people
really respected and then they were
convicted for offenses and then they
disappear and so I this project began
it's really a personal interest that I
saw the headlines this is 2000 2008
Enron Worldcon Computer Associates are
still very much in the headline and that
evening out of personal curiosity this
isn't a scholarly project at all at this
point
I did what I think a lot of people had
in the back of the mind when they were
reading The Wall Street Journal New York
Times stories what were some of these
guys thinking and I thought maybe if I
could do what they were doing on the
show a little bit just spend some time
talking with them I might see a
different perspective so give us a kind
of a sampling or a list of who it is
that you spoke to so over the course of
the last 7 years roughly 50 people most
of which were convicted criminally some
some cases civilly and couple case
there's actually been cases have been
overturned but some little prominent
name the executive from Enron dennis
Kozlowski the former CEO of Tyco people
convicted of pandu screams the two most
well known Bernie Madoff and Alan
Stanford
number one and two on the largest Ponzi
schemes in recent history and how did
you approach them and more importantly
why do you think they agreed to talk to
you which is a great question as an
attorney asking that so I approached
them with a I think a as a educator I'm
someone that teaches this material to my
students at Harvard Business School and
this is not something that a student
would ever think kind of sanction they
would ever think they would face and so
I wanted sequel how did some of these
individuals some of which are alum of
the school in which I teach at what
happened along the way so write a short
letter I would like to better understand
your perspective could we spend some
time together and so that first night
when I sent those first ten questions I
received a number of responses some
people actually someone from global head
of sales from Computer Associates Steven
Richards was really quite elegant
eight-page cursive letter back
describing from the challenges that he
faced others like Dennis kozlovsky said
I'm happy to chat I have plenty of time
now come visit me he's in a prison in
upstate New York and so what I did was
just start taking them up on this offer
what started as maybe a half an hour
here a letter there an email if they
were in federal prison email back and
forth through a special system began
something that it became more apparent
to me that it was interesting and
actually quite humbling speaking of some
of these quite extraordinary and
intelligent individuals that now made
such consequential sanctions to hear
their perspective as to why they spoke
with me I think one thing that I'm
privileged in being an academic at HBS
is that I could commit to spend as much
time as I really needed to to try to
understand their perspective so I could
come in fat I'm not going to try to
write something or teach them in my
class at the end of the week the
journalist might have a deadline I can
spend weeks months in some cases number
of people I've spent years corresponding
gain to know to try to really understand
how they see they see the world because
that's the ultimate goal of the project
also I think many of them simply just
missed their business world and you know
I'm
I keep finance we can talk about the
financial crisis we can talk about
what's going on other firms and much of
our conversation was not about their
case actually much of the most revealing
aspects of my conversations was talking
about everything else what was going to
Wall Street Journal they were reading I
would send them books that I was reading
in the signing in class and hearing what
they had to say versus my colleagues and
students was oftentimes just fascinating
did you talk to family members victims
and others that were sort of around
these individuals and the crimes that
were committed I did in a number of
instances I mean much more of my focus
it was was on the individual but in
number of instance their family members
and in in many of the cases I'm actually
on much of the corresponds it seems to
be sent among among the family which I
think it's very easy and I think I
approach it's like many people
externally when you see this is
extraordinary crime that caused such
devastation to say someone's going to
get a year in prison or two years in
prison that doesn't seem very much and
like to see what that does to a family
what would someone your kids it's really
quite extraordinary and I think coming
even if the sanction is quote short not
seeing from their perspective of their
family it's been interesting also to you
now that people start to get out of
prison that I initially spent time how
some people are finding different things
to do and some cases actually I was like
flourishing in a different way and other
people are stuck having having these
sanctions on them or something that can
never overcome in victims I mean
especially in some cases like Madoff I
mean some people were just really truly
devastated by his actions and and part
of my goal of speaking to the victims
was actually then to go back to someone
like very made up and say I just had
this conversation can you can you help
me try to understand why this doesn't
seem to be resonating with you and
that's where I think I learned something
about their personalities how that some
cases just didn't seem to settle in that
there was there was really people on the
other side that had lost everything and
I guess I guess I would ask the question
of whether or not you thought they were
truthful with you although perhaps the
way you describe it
you weren't necessarily in the business
of trying to determine what the truth
wasn't confronting them with it is that
right yeah there's the the broader goals
I'll say their subjective view of the
world I think I wanted to be able to try
to put myself in their shoes and see how
they viewed the world now their own
cases and you know I think is I mean any
prosecutor knows and defense knows that
people's memories even even they're
trying to be truthful they evolve and
change and to be good when it comes to
their cases so even in the best case
scenario that they were trying to be
truthful it's hard to remember all the
details but on top of this most of them
are convicted felons so to rely on
truthfulness would be probably a little
naive right am i apart but this is why I
did try to rely on much more of the
other information that was going around
their case at a time I mean for example
we have a lot of emails in some cases
they would show me that they weren't
worrying after they completed a deal in
one case for Enron they weren't worrying
that night after they signed the papers
they were actually going out celebrating
and described how they went out with
their with their spouses and so that
piece of information is more powerful
it's not something that was widely
reported or are if you know what people
are doing after you can kind of back up
probably what they were thinking a
little bit better time or their
immediate reaction and so that's what I
was trying to do is piece it together in
a different way but ultimately
subjective the suggestion by some of
them was I didn't run to my defense
lawyer that night I went out and had a
party so therefore I really wasn't
intentionally doing anything wrong well
I don't think I don't want say
intentionally but they weren't worrying
about what they were doing which i think
is something different that we all do
things that are are wrong and this is
kind of one of the themes in the book we
all do things that we all speed driving
a car we know that's wrong but we still
do it
but if we know that something is
actually harmful is going to create some
kind of significant personal harm or
devastation we generally have a much
deeper pause before going ahead argue in
many cases this is what prevents us from
even considering an option in the first
place and so in May these cases I think
they could know though they were pushing
something aggressively could be wrong
but this was the
to a slap slap on the wrist this
wouldn't lead to the kind of
consequences that we described in this
book that would really offend an
otherwise really privileged life in a
lot of cases so let me ask you what is
the what do you think is the difference
if there is one between the white-collar
criminal on the one hand and those who
commit other types of crimes be they
physical crimes like burglary or drug
crimes or assault is there a fundamental
difference between the profile of the
perpetrator I think it links to the
profile of the perpetrator and the crime
itself so that the thing that's
different about most white collar
offenses is you don't actually have to
get close to the victim so there's this
occurs in two ways that the victims
themselves and most white collar
offenses are distant oftentimes quite
amorphous so think of something like
insider trading it's difficult to
actually identify the the actual name of
the individuals that we could say it's
more broadly a more of a systematic it
creates a harm to the financial system
as a as a whole no doubt our anonymous
persons on the other side of the trade
anonymous persons on the other sides of
trades true so we can think of they
exist ain't no doubt and this is not to
say it doesn't exist but you can't pick
them out and actually see see their
picture in other cases even when there
are you could say identifiable victims
the time in which they are actually
going to be identified is actually
offset so think of something like a
Ponzi scheme it's a time you're actually
harming the individuals by investing in
some non-existent investment scheme
think of bernie madoff investors were
clamoring to give him more money they
were trying to give him more leadership
positions in industry he could come home
and actually most of the day looked
pretty good it's only when it's revealed
later that all this starts to unwind and
it becomes so clear that there were
actually people being harmed rather than
and so this is why not I always found it
interesting that I could spend and I did
spend hundreds of hours with individuals
in a room I never once worried about one
of these guys if I turned around going
to my back pocket stealing and stealing
you know $20 out of my wallet
but many of these individuals through
you know funds that I owned retirement
account actually have actually taken far
more than $20 from me now the question
is will why do I never need to worry
about them stealing $20 my wallet but
many of them would without very much
form or steal a couple hundred from my
account and I think that's the
fundamental difference in terms of these
crimes that you can actually do some
pretty devastating things and not have
that gut feeling of actually doing
something harmed even being a reasonably
socialized person as opposed to putting
a knife at somebody's throat and
demanding their wallet right which is I
think takes in many cases a
fundamentally either different kind of
person or a different kind of
desperation or circumstances you also I
think point out in the book in addition
to the anonymity of the victim and the
sort of the longer period of time it
takes for the victim to be revealed it's
the act itself I think you in the book
talk about how these crimes are often
committed by the click of a mouse or
erasing and putting in a new number on a
balance sheet is the nature of the Act
also something that distinguishes the
white-collar criminal from others that's
that's a great point I mean you can
actually create extraordinary
devastation there's one one case in
which someone actually uses the the
white thought feature in Excel and it's
able to make calculations that would
ultimately cause hundreds of millions of
dollars in a loss for for for the firm
and that's that's pretty noise it takes
three seconds it doesn't feel all that
all that harmful at the time I mean it's
really the click of a mouse or signing
the paper one of the people that was
prosecuted after the passage of
sarbanes-oxley Steven Garfunkel a former
CFO he described how it was he was
ultimately prosecuted for signing in a
significant amount of false collateral
and that he was actually comfortable and
comfortable but didn't feel that bad
about signing many many documents
attesting to a false letter of
collateral it didn't seem like that big
of a lot you're assigning a sheet of
paper kind of so what and it was only
once he
actually was actually confronted by
someone actually was a banker who
actually didn't think the numbers made a
lot of sense and actually confront him
that these numbers just don't line up
that he was going to be forced to lie to
someone face to face and that's
something that's at that point he
unwounded he he said it's a lie this
doesn't make sense and that's when
everything so this is in consent most
subtle distinction of lying on papers
very easy lying to someone to the face
is harder and we can kind of keep
escalating from there mm-hmm
so does the fact that does this give you
some insight potentially and do how one
might better deter white-collar crime
knowing how it is different from other
types of crimes that then give you any
insider did you reach any conclusions
about how best to prevent it so this is
the big challenge challenging a
challenging question I mean the one
thing that did as I initially surprised
me but then over time it became
something I came to expect is that most
most of these people even when they were
doing something pretty egregious the
kind of thing that is going to land you
in prison this isn't a but gray this
isn't if we hire some great lawyers we
can probably get out of this this is
something once it's detected you're
going to prison for some period of time
still found ways of not seeing that they
were ever going to go to prison
and that's pretty I think extraordinary
thing to realize that even if you do
something really wrong that you never
see that outcome happening
it suggests that maybe a different
regulatory approach or a way we need to
think about that this isn't if this
isn't a deliberate cost-benefit
calculation because if it's explicit
cost-benefit calculation there's two
ways to increase the cost we can either
increase the probability being caught or
we increase the sentence once caught and
I think the historical approach that
we've taken over the last several
decades has been let's increase the cost
associated with with being once you're
caught so rather than a potential
sentence of one year it goes from three
years or five years or in some cases
there's several law school faculty that
in some cases they actually argue that
some of the senses actually look
actually potentially even too long when
we compare them to serious personal yes
I think there was one
citing your book that you know about a
twelve million dollar fraud that impacts
shareholders in the 1980s was punishable
by approximately three years in prison
whereas by the early 2000s that it
increased fourfold to I think somewhere
between 13 and 16 years in prison for
the same offense obviously a drastic
increase in in in penalties and
sanctions and fines but your point seems
to be that that may not have much of an
impact on deterring my collar crime I
think if it was if many of these people
and we're talking about the most
privileged people here so it is a
specific type of individual but it
whether you go to prison for six months
or you go to prison for three years that
idea is not resonating I think in most
of these cases you still think that
that's for someone else it's those guys
that go to prison not me about the fact
of prison as opposed to the light of the
term so I think the fact in prison so
this goes to the other the other way if
this goes to much broader set of norms
that this stuff is this stuff is wrong
it's going to have really serious
sanctions associated with it which could
be you know very heavily financial
pennies but could could be in prison but
that's something that people normalize
and that this is what happens to people
that do this kind of thing if that
actually was in people's mind I think
that would change but that's a much more
of a that's not a clock benefit
calculation anymore that strikes me is
that becomes part of our norms and
culture about what's actually
appropriate and what's not appropriate
and I think the challenge for regulators
in that case is you need resources to I
mean you can in order to detect more
cases especially some of the more
difficult cases need the amount of
resources to to police which is which is
challenging because this is obviously a
political consideration of how many how
much resources do two investigators have
mm-hmm what about if white-collar
criminals you find don't really make
that cost-benefit analysis then do you
or in your book do you have any
suggestions on how it is that that this
crime can be better deter
so I go back to the individual at the
end which is my view and this is my view
of human nature's that the people in
here are not predisposed or have any
inclination to actually want of want to
do something criminal these are the
things that does that happen because of
the the settings that they're exposed to
their norms the cultures in which they
grow up within within a firm and the
pressures that they face I think of it
standpoint for example a business school
student there's not one business school
student when they're about to leave a
prestigious business school that says I
my goal is I'm going to go out become a
tiny ministry become wealthy improve the
industry you know be Anna speaking at
commencement
donate to a lot of wonderful
organizations and then maybe near the
end of my career I might engage in some
fraud or insider trading no one thinks
like that mm-hmm
but what we can find is cases of people
doing exactly that Rajat Gupta is in a
prime example of this I mean come on I
tell us about mr. Gupta I mean Roger
cook and about this extraordinary career
as one can have more than three decades
of McKinsey & Company one of the most
well respected firms in the world
eventually CEOs in the managing director
yes so became the lead person of one
most celebrated firm sports culture and
what it what it means and then you look
at after his retirement is he's on the
board of a number of prestigious firms
goldman sachs one of them and 20 at one
point twenty three seconds after goldman
sachs board meeting he's calling a
well-known billionaire hedge fund raj
ron autumn and divulging confidential
information I mean this is against
everything that that he didn't like to
become successful I mean you don't
become the head of McKinsey by not being
thoughtful reflective intelligent
protecting client confidences well let
me stop you right there for a moment I
guess because I was going to say the
cynic but maybe it's not limited to
cynics might suggest well that's exactly
the kind of approach and conduct that
gets you ahead in the business world
it's not a place necessarily
we're Essex and morality prevail but
it's those persons who operate in the
gray area and maybe even cross the gray
area to get ahead and so what mr. Gupta
might have done was simply an extension
perhaps of how he how he operated in
McKinsey
it could be I mean it's it's impossible
to fully rule that out
so one thing well I do think about the
case of both Rajat Gupta and Anil Kumar
the other partner at McKinsey
is that one of the most cherished values
had a place like McKinsey its client
confidentiality and this is a place
where you don't talk an elevator about
your clients you don't even tell your
spouse in many cases you go to st. Louis
but you don't tell which firm you're
working for it's it would be pretty
remarkable to be able to spend decades
in that type of culture and on one hand
be able to teach it lead it and do it
successfully around Cohn client
confidentiality and it's a not respect
that and still still succeed at least as
I look at in both of these cases so both
Gupta and Kumar is that they were
exposed they were successful when they
were in the confines in McKinsey culture
strong culture reinforcing these norms
and intuitions about we protect client
confidences that's what we do but that's
an artificial norm or intuition that's
not something where we have inborn it's
not something we've been evolutionary
designed to protect something we learn
to do we're exposed to that type of
culture certainly if you're exposed to a
different type of culture that of a
corrupt hedge fund crowd fund manager
you're going to develop that kind of
culture and so when they start
interacting with people that that differ
from that which one may argue as you're
saying perhaps in some cases this could
have occurred earlier but I'll say what
we know unambiguously is in both cases
when these individuals were operating
and spending time with someone that very
much acted differently they adopted that
different type of culture that that much
grayer that much more aggressive I mean
it ultimately undermined something that
I mean that's that's a little disturbing
because it suggests that culture and
even morality is perhaps more temporary
than we would like to believe that once
you're out from under the environment
that encourages and fosters moral
behavior and and a good conduct that you
become susceptible to crossing the line
I agree
exactly I think that's the challenge we
generally spend a lot of time I mean
their aisles and aisles imagine books so
talked about in business schools in some
cases about moral character values moral
compass and that's nice to think about
and to believe that if we if we have the
set of moral values sitting here today
this is how I'll be going out in any
sort of circumstance or situation but
I'll say the psychological evidence
pushes very heavily back in that saying
that the situations far dominates the
individual person but we can see in a
lot of I think these incidents that you
spend 40 or 50 hours in a business
school classroom taking an ethics class
or you could spend a couple weeks at a
corporate training program that's going
to be dominated by about four days forty
hours in the classroom that's equivalent
if you go to a major bank that's
equivalent about your first four days on
the job three or four days so presumably
whatever culture you've been exposed
with by day five at that financial
institution it's going to dominate
whatever experience you might have had
in a classroom or training exercise and
and that's the culture that you're going
to adopt and I think well I think we
tend to ascribe morality as being this
this value that that's above or greater
than culture I see it driven largely by
cultural norms in a lot of these
instances that people can aspire and I
think most cases people do aspire to do
well but when facing tremendous pressure
and and the wrong incentives we see
people doing things that are different I
think in the recent Wells Fargo case
that's been obviously obviously in the
news I mean we have a case where in a
Wells Fargo actually had an effective
culture and that they had several
thousand people doing exactly what the
firm incentivized but simultaneously one
of the challenges that the firm face is
that those incentives led people to do
things that were clearly going to lead
to a whole host of regulatory challenges
and so then the question is well and
this where it really becomes you could
say tone from the top
although that's a little too like a
catchphrase that right but what is the
culture that's actually being set within
a firm because that's what's going to
motivate people's incentives and
ultimately it or their ethics so I get
to the fundamental question of why they
do it and you kind of have a very
interesting portion of the book where
you sort of survey the theories as to
why white-collar criminals do what they
do going back to the 1800s including I
thought someone somewhat curiously the
view that prevailed at some point in
time that suggested you could actually
tell who was going to be a white-collar
criminal by the way they looked their
physical appearance like high forehead
and a pointed nose might suggest you
going to be embezzler is that khane tell
us a little bit about that theory of
course so actually if this interview is
being taking place in in 1939 I would
not be the person that would be here it
would actually be a colleague from
Harvard earnest Hooton who is the head
of our anthropology department he was
the most well-respected person in the
country when it came to talking about
criminality why crime occurs and how he
came about this as an answer he's a
physical anthropologist so that the
shape and size of bodies what he did is
he did one of the most complete studies
of criminals still even by today's
standards which a the laboratory of
graduate students go out and to ten
thousand convicted felons around prisons
around the country and he took a couple
hundred measurements measurements of the
kind of the length of the earlobe the
angle the nose the breadth of eyelashes
a couple hundred the most comprehensive
this was still the prevailing view over
the last 150 years before this that
something about the individuals body is
related to their propensity and he
thought well the trick is I just need to
do this more carefully than with more
rigor that we got to get a lot of
careful detailed empirical measurements
and in 1939 Harvard University publishes
his book describing at criminality and
he actually has a and one kind of
wonderful played in the book showing
what a white-collar offender looks like
the four
years in fraudsters an example and he
says he gives us six or seven
characteristics and if the person looks
like this they are a going to be the
white collar offenders it would actually
be this available it had this actually
turned out to be true this would have
actually been wonderful for for most
regulators we could dispense with all
the complexities here and exactly you
could just serve through a database of
photos but we turned out that that died
out as a theory very much I mean in part
because he was a leading proponent of
actually eugenics and people started to
see how this was correlated with some of
his arguments and turned out they were
they left ultimately scientific rigor it
was a lot of faulty correlations but the
theory has had totally gone away and
that there's actually a criminologist
from the University of Pennsylvania
Adrienne rein who's actually done some
very interesting work which started he's
a neuro criminologist
so it's he looked at it's not the
person's face or body shape that's
causing but it's their mind we just need
to go deeper inside the body and so he's
done some really fascinating work mostly
looking at violent offenders looking at
people that engage in spousal abuse or
murder have some type of different blame
makeup but seems to make them more have
a higher propensity associated with
conveying these offenses and he's
actually done one recent paper with one
of the colleagues at Wharton that does
business ethics where they brought in a
number of low-level white collar
offenders and it started very
preliminary which they acknowledged
maybe see some differences in in brain
structure associated with people who are
predefined so they have a higher
capacity almost for almost intelligence
which is pretty a humble and conclusion
but it shows that this theory is still
around just in a different different
different way I'll say a more careful
way I mean ultimately the arguments
around whether it's a physical cause I
mean there's a psychopathy there there
are explanations in some of them but
I'll say many of the people I spent time
with it the difference between them and
having exactly come to my class that's a
prime
CEO or CFO now if I was to not have
their CVS
I could flip around their CVS and I
don't think most people will be able to
tell tell the difference
they're cordial intelligent everything
you'd expect a corporate leader to be so
the idea that there's a I'll say a
physical cause for white-collar criminal
T right is the sole explanation it can
contribute but it's probably not the
answer so what what is the bottom line
inclusion from your book is it you've
identified culture as one one cause is
it also situational just the circum the
set of circumstances come together and
create a perfect storm that makes
someone who otherwise wouldn't cross the
line to do so what what conclusion did
you ultimately reach so how I came here
and think about white-collar crime is it
doesn't look like so much of what I
think is a failure of managerial
reasoning you can actually what even
appeals
it looks like reasoning to us is
oftentimes not actual genuine reasoning
a lot of times it's just justifying
something we previously thought and we
we think we're going back and forth but
we have wonderful psychological evidence
I suggest that that's what we originally
thought it it actually comes down to our
intuition so I see most much of the
failures a failure of managerial
intuition rather than reasoning and
that's just it's certainly different you
could say it would take a different tack
or approach to to address some of the
these values so by that you mean you
mean managers manage based a lot on
intuition and gut instinct and they just
don't give a lot of thought to those
situations when what their instinct is
telling them is to do something that
they should know better than to do
exactly if they don't have that initial
gut instinct telling them kind of
screaming out that this is going to be
very harmful or devastating so I think
going back to the speeding example we
all know it's wrong but to the extent
you're speeding you don't really feel
any your gut doesn't bubble up and
suggest you're doing something really
heinous and terrible although it could
be some really serious consequence
associated with that if your propensity
of hurting someone actually goes up but
that doesn't strike us in our gut as
we're doing something it's a statistical
harm what we need to do is is actually
think of white-collar crimes in some
cases kind of like being where you might
know you're doing something wrong but
you're able to rationalize or justify it
it's not so bad other people are doing
it or I'll say in some instances you're
not even thinking about until someone
brings it up to you until your spouse is
next to you and tells you to Eugene slow
down you're going too fast this is not
or I think in your books I mentioned if
you see an accident or you see a police
car
you might slow down because all of a
sudden you're reminded right eye and
those reminders often often lack I mean
how I think is that a lot of these
situations that we think of we could
think of them as ethical dilemmas or
just doing the right versus the wrong
thing these are very easy to solve if we
were to sit down with a sheet of paper
and look at them you don't need an
elaborate discussion to figure out
should you call someone after a board
meeting within 20 seconds and and
divulge confidential information that's
not really a difficult ethical dilemma
but why do we see people in many cases
really quite brilliant people falling
prey to these we could say simple
failures and this is where the the
classroom and training is very different
than the real world in training you're
given the dilemma someone point it out
should you do this or shouldn't you do
this its isolate from the hundreds of
other decisions you're making you also
see that there are people in the room
that will think differently than you so
often a corporate saying that lack so
though there's a lot of corporate
governance ideas we need independent
directors a lot of that is in some cases
checking the box that you from a
regulatory perspective you have some of
that being independent but it's not
generally independent in terms of
thought in a pane it's not going to
bring lean in pushback on a CEO when
it's a privileged position right and
let's talk about that because I you have
a very interesting story about Mark
Whitacre from Archer Daniels Midland and
what it is that ultimately convinced him
that the conduct that he was engaged in
was in
right so I mean he was a rising star by
the way the focus of the movie The
Insider right with Matt Matt Matt Matt
Damon probably one of the most
high-profile people to play you know
someone that was convicted of a
white-collar offense
so he was a rising star at a ADM and in
the course when he was promoted to a
more senior senior divisional they they
basically finally brought him under the
ropes tell me this is how business is
really done which is there was global
price-fixing on a number of these these
chemical products that are used a very
very important food industry where you
go to your people within the Japanese
people in Europe and they sit around it
and literally figure out how they should
set the prices there was one it's an old
opera oh this is blamele illegal and
they also as I read wrote down false
names in their expense reports so
there'd be no evidence of who they met
with traffic tracking it down I mean
they you could say they put a fair
amount of effort I mean this this was
going on this wasn't someone that came
up one day this has been going up first
pretty clear to mark Whitacre that he
knew what he was doing was wrong well
[ __ ] you would say it should have been I
mean I think there was some hint that
this was probably some apprehension when
but again this is how one of most
successful firms in the country has been
doing it this is what the senior Pelt
people tell you that this is what we're
doing if you want to stay in that
position of privilege you feel like you
you adapt to what that team is telling
you but where that unwinds is one night
when he goes home he's actually talking
to his wife ginger and it's just
describing what he's doing and his wife
reacts with was just shocked but this
isn't what who you are mark this doesn't
represent what you should be doing and
you know this is wrong and it really
took someone almost quite physically
shake him someone that he respected and
trusted but someone I'd also said
completely outside this business and
wasn't a contaminate in many ways by by
these different norms and intuitions
that that were being created within ADM
and at that point he became a
whistleblower actually one the most
senior and in history and actually was
then started secretly taping many of
these these reports what's maybe tragic
but also said something in this case is
becomes a whistleblower for the
government that it's a point he is
actually a whistleblower he did
something you could argue even more
shocking he actually starts essentially
embezzling notably he doesn't talk to
his wife at this time about this and so
he keeps doing it and if you're a
government informant while your
informant doing a crime is you've
increased your propensity being caught
by some high degree an ultimately ends
up going to prison for for not actually
the offense his wife helped them you can
say take the best route out of he had at
a time right be ends up going prison for
doing something else right stupid so so
this suggests that perhaps one route to
decreasing the level of white-collar
crime is to populate companies and
corporations with persons who are
outside the culture but who are there
and present during decision-making so
that they can offer you know a voice
that's maybe untainted by the groupthink
that may occur in some companies I've
heard of this happening in some
companies you think that's a viable
viable solution
if companies can be actually endeavor to
do that in a genuine and genuine way I
think but there's a tremendous
opportunity there I I mean the challenge
is that so much of this comes down to
compliance and things that we need to do
to follow rules so what many firms do is
when we're trying to avoid or responding
to some kind of regulatory problem we we
Institute more rules we bring in more
compliance people to create more rules
willful very sometimes very smart people
you see more rules and what do you do it
just requires a little bit more thought
of how to keep doing what I used to do
before but now stay within the bounds of
the rule which is a really a perverse
outcome we've seen a lot of these cases
where what you much rather have is
people come in and sit back and say is
this actually what you're supposed to be
doing is this actually represent why you
went to this firm and reflects what
you're trying to do in this industry but
that requires a very different approach
I mean one area where I've spent time is
talking a role that attorneys play I
actually believe that a lot of firms
attorneys but they play the role called
comp
so but counsel is generally referred to
in the legal conduct where you're
actually giving legal advice about what
is appropriate or not a program when it
comes to the laws and regulations but at
least I can say from talking to speaking
to many senior managers is they actually
are looking to that attorney because
that is someone that operates because
it's an outside counsel it actually
someone is operating outside that has
the ability to to see that culture
potentially differently the challenge I
think that counsel plays in this case is
that the morning you're hired because
you're reflecting what the client client
wants at the same time potentially what
the client wants in that moment is
different from what they really would
like in their long-term interest and I
think this is something you know
speaking to colleagues at law school and
people friends that are their attorneys
it's something where I actually think
outside counsel could actually play a
far greater leadership role and actually
knowing that you're not just the person
about whether people are following the
rules and regulations but but actually
in some cases you're the chief xyx
officer in some cases that's a much more
humbling position I know and I talked to
colleagues in law school they they shy
away when you when you bring in the
world of ethics in this context but I
think this is where we see managers
sometimes wanting to offset in some
sense those those obligations to someone
else or give them some time this is
attorneys it could also be accountants
when it comes to technical accounting
matters but I think historically this is
not the run the rule where accountants
and attorneys are generally viewed as
the people who are going to jump in the
room and actually give it a different
ethical lens yes I mean look I think I
think a lot more of that goes on then
probably is given credit for that
outside service providers and advisers
prevent companies and individuals from
taking certain action but a lot of that
just doesn't show up in the statistics
because it never it never happened on
the other hand there are circumstances
where it appears that the attorneys the
accounts and others are actually enable
errs seem to be facilitating the
wrongdoing conduct and that often does
come back so asymmetry is it's a little
asymmetry there yeah well maybe the
solution then is you should have imagine
a boardroom or management
with all the members of management or
the board around a table you just need
to have all their spouses and
significant others around the perimeter
of the room whispering in their ears
when them when the moral compass goes
off that I would actually do probably a
lot of good in some of these cases just
just a generally different view I give
the one example of Ben Ben Horowitz a
well-known venture at venture capitalist
it was probably when the most
interesting up but when I when I came
across this originally something is
going to write a lot and his biography
but him he's a well-known well really
celebrated venture capitalist and when
he hired a new CFO for one of his firms
the CFO came in and looked at the
compensation arrangements and said you
know I see we're doing one thing that
looks not that competitive when I look
at other firms in Silicon Valley it
turns out that most of our competitors
other firms with a sign off of in some
cases both their lawyers and accountants
but they adjust the option date to make
it the most attractive for for senior
executives Ben's initial response was
this this looks this looks great
obviously we probably need to do this
this is you know looks like basically a
free lunch additional compensation with
no additional risk but he realized that
his intuitions around when it came to
finance technical finance and accounting
manners might not be perfect he's a
strict a strategist at heart he's an
innovative thinker but he's not a
technical finance and accounting guy so
he had a routine procedure that he
always wanted to go to to a counsel
outside counsel just to bring some of
that set outside this little environment
that occurred not just you could say
within the firm but within Silicon
Valley
passed it by him friends friend and
attorney comes back I looked over this
pile of different ways and there's no
way that this makes any sense that this
can be legal i I recommend against it
Ben went back to the CFO said you know
what I know everyone else is doing it's
true many other firms were doing it but
it's not it's not for it's not for us
fast forward two years this becomes part
of the big options backdating scandal
right and and the CFO X is fairly
enables one of the people that actually
went to prison for this right and it's
been reflects on this it dis isn't
because he had a better moral compass or
better values than other executives in
the industry but simply because he had a
better you could call it a
system encounter controls I almost think
it's like a personal preservation
framework where he knew where his
weaknesses lie a lie it's not a finance
and accounting guy he he also knew that
getting advice from just the little
inner circle might not always be right
and so he anticipated this and know know
how to design system that could
intercede before he might have so I'll
say this is a fascinating incident or I
think this comes down to humility and
self-awareness he was aware of when he
he he might be compromised and knew how
to design system which I actually right
give him a lot of credit for it right so
let's talk about some of the individuals
you spoke to and I guess let's start
with Bernie Madoff so tell us about your
interactions with Bernie Madoff and you
also in the book identify a particular
episode that I think one might describe
is a little chilling
what gave at least according to the book
I think a little insight into his
character so so a very amazing someone
that I've been corresponding with for
years now I mean every Wednesday night
for for a couple years we would speak on
the phone hundreds of pages of
correspondence back back and forth of
this time I mean he was a well respected
leader in the financial industry
I mean main innovations we think about
when it comes to this NASDAQ
decimalisation can be attributed to
advances at his firm but simultaneously
Bernie Madoff also just started out with
this investment management business that
grew to become one of the largest Ponzi
schemes in history so despite the fact
that but he create one largest Ponzi
schemes III still see if someone that he
was never destined to create this
massive failure but then the question is
well well what what happened how does
this end so I spent a lot of time
talking with him trying to understand
how how this problem grew and why he can
never get get out of it I mean one of
the things I always found very humbling
when I do think of his cases I think
most of us like to believe and I think
probably quite rightly that we would
never let something grow like this and
become get out of control which is what
happened this case eventually stops even
trading there's no underlying business
that's right it's apply to screaming in
that classic sense that there
no way he could have imagined by the
late 90s that he could have ever got out
of this the question though is at what
point and the question I've asked myself
and that if people around you are
putting you on a pedestal clamoring to
give you more money you go home on
Friday night you have dinner with your
your wife your two kids and then you say
you know what this is enough I should
call the SEC I should call the the DOJ
because this needs to end I think most
of us what we would do is say we know
this needs to end I'll do that next week
and then next week comes and what it's
the same repeat you say I know this is
wrong it needs to stop but I don't want
to end it right now and watch everything
I've done collapse and I think if I
think bringing like that that's a that's
a fairly humbling and difficult question
to ask how many of us would have that
character to actually after that final
dinner with our family decide today
we're going to end it even though not
being fourth maybe long sentences our
deterrent to confession oh this is
actually that's that's a very
provocative way that had the sentence in
habit I mean he he has a life sentence I
mean he's essentially effectively
sentenced to you know it the second he
turned himself in he would never have
another meal with his family that's
right that's that's interesting way of
framing it but I think when it comes to
well why this happened the first place
how did you start growing why didn't he
potentially like climb down and this is
where Bernie Madoff is different than
than any other people I spent time with
I mean unlike the other people which you
know I described as people who engaged
in crimes who might have devastated
people but they didn't know then they
see those victims on a daily basis they
were distant or amorphous
psychologically that's not true for
Madoff these were those family friends
people in the Jewish community which is
what how do when you know that these
people are going to lose money how do
you still say it's okay to give me your
money to family member X and that's
something that makes them I think these
were not very dinner the remote victims
we spoke about earlier and the today you
could say actually the extreme
these were substance the most close
members that he was spending time around
and so referring to the you know one of
the infants where I'm trying to
understand his his personality how he
views the world you know we would
normally have our our talks Wednesday
evening prepared both of its sons while
he was in prison died one committed
suicide on anniversary of when you turn
himself in and the other actually died
died of cancer and I was reading a
actually obituary when his second son
died it just popped up on Reuters and I
was reading it literally just came out
and I picked up the phone and it turned
out that this calls from a federal
prison do you accept this call of
sitting in my office and surprised
because I didn't have a call scheduled
at this time with with anyone but of
course I accepted the call and it was
Bernie Madoff and I'll say this is one
of them my stomach just sunk when I
heard his voice because I'm reading the
obituary his son at that it there the
exact moment and you're tossing
someone's father and he said he just
heard on the radio and he asked if I
could read him the the obituary and this
is something where I've been fortunate
my life I haven't had deliver or speak
to people that better it's that I mean
the truth you could say the hardest
points in one's life a loss of a child
so I took it on my researcher had his
off I'm just you know another person so
I read I read the obituary to him and
yeah I'm not a loss of what to say after
you know I'm so sorry
if there's anything I can do maybe he
wants me to pass a note along to someone
or a message up I don't know I lost what
right what do you say to someone in this
situation right and he says I'm fine I'm
fine then there's a pause then he says
what can we go back and actually talk
about the interest rates that we were
actually talking about last Wednesday
and for the next 11 minutes we talk
about interest with interest rates I'll
say he was talking about so I stood in
first grade III and then when I still
think about this and it comes back it's
kind of this haunting I go back I went
home and my wife saw me I think pal that
this was the most disconcerting
conversation I want to see I've had my
life and that I don't think this was I
mean the first reaction
was maybe he was in shock and this was
you talk about something different
because right I don't think it was that
the following Wednesday when we speak we
go back to talking about great it was
this was an issue and I think for for
four minutes he was focused on it and it
was you know sad and devastating but
then you can compartmentalize that and
then you switch and it's it's as easy as
be able to switch it and this is
something where his psychological makeup
is just different most most of us don't
have that capacity to to
compartmentalize which i think is what
actually helped facilitate that he could
see his world operating these different
buckets and right you had to
compartmentalize them in in a way that
right so when he was soliciting money
from someone all that was perhaps was
for injustice solicitation but the
consequences and the ramifications and
all that would flow from that was not
something that entered his mind at that
time right and I mean and something
which I've never and I don't think he
would he can differentiate these two
things is that in most cases he would be
telling people I can't take your money
right now and in part on one hand you
could say he looks back I told people to
not give me more money strictly speaking
that seems to been true in a lot of
instances it's actually that marketing
pitch which is something we could teach
in business school telling people to not
give me your money actually makes people
want to give your money more and so you
can't separate whether that was good
nature from that's that's a great
marketing pitch I generally believe it
was probably a great marketing pitch and
he in the back of his mind he could
rationalize that I told them not to give
me money so if they give me their money
that's that's their fault now which is a
they're pretty sinister rationalization
to blaming the victim yeah
I'm deceiving them but I've given them
you know it's it's the classic where you
get the you know eight thousand line
contract when you're about to click on
something online and the firm can say
well allowing six thousand two hundred
twenty three we told you that that could
happen so it's not our fault that you
clicked on the okay where that's not a
reasonable way into that doesn't that
doesn't make it not deceptive are there
you have so many interesting stories in
the book
about individual individual white-collar
criminals are there others that stick
out in your mind I know
for example allen Stanford who took a
very different view and blamed everyone
including the US government for his
wrongdoing and claimed that there was no
wrongdoing at all that was one of the
most I'll say extra you could say
extreme that this was not any fault of
my own this was purely and I mean goes
at length in the book is anything short
of the pages I could give on and that
this is a fault of the US government I
mean what what's interesting is as case
we can separate two parts is that here's
one of the few cases in which I you
could say a financial institution but
I'll put that in quotes was shut down
prior to its failure which on one hand
which is the goal of law enforcement we
could say it's to want to stop it before
more victims are created step the ironic
part is most of time in the financial
industry
things collapse things go bankrupt fraud
is known and then receivership kicks and
other things so you could argue the best
case scenario is to stop it before
before the thing collapses and everyone
loses anything now what's ironic is he
actually looks at that well there were
other firms that that could have failed
that they didn't have government
bailouts or whatnot I didn't take
government bailout and they put me in
receivership and so he kind of uses the
you could say the logic that because I
didn't fail I it it must be legitimate
it is a way of I think providing some
comfort that but this was not his fault
that this was someone else and it's a
challenging question I mean I think if
there's a 99.9% chance that firms going
to fail we could say makes a lot of
sense for for to be taken over if I were
able to place a 1% chance that might be
shuttering the legitimate business now I
think what the receivership and other
documents prosecutors put together
suggest that this is closer to the 99%
side he sees this is more of the 1% side
which I mean the allegations as I recall
or that there were misrepresentations
about what he was doing with the money I
mean there was so that hard argue that
he would have succeeded had the
government not stepped in and if you
look at the management I did spend
time you know trying to say I mean have
his into the extensions business let's
say was legitimate he should be one of
the greatest investors I mean Warren
Buffett should be calling him for advice
if you look at the rate of return he was
able to generate and I give the old an
example that you know he provided that
there was one Ecuadorian IPO that
produced you know great thirty percent
or something returned to generate the
returns that he did over decades there
should been hundreds of hundreds of
deals in you it should look like
Berkshire Hathaway Warren Buffett right
it doesn't
I mean he's CFO I mean the CFO the firm
an old college buddy of his I mean his
CFO was into some pretty nasty things I
mean he essentially stole the money in a
trust when his wife died that was meant
for his kids and then ultimately success
if you look at all the other major
executives of firm ultimately they
turned in either government witnesses or
essentially whistleblowers at the very
end that none of them knew what the
business actually was and you can
actually see the internal emails going
back in the form where we don't ask
questions we just sell this stuff that
it makes it much harder to think that
there was a actually legitimate business
that he only knew about and no one else
can find so he has a nice break believe
but the the receivership continues to
document more and more evidence
suggesting that there were no real
investor or there was no I mean six cent
I mean different Madoff there was you
could say there was in investments but
you know buying a you know a golf course
or some land for a couple hundred
million dollars and then moving around
and marketing up to three billion
dollars is that's not the investment
generating a legitimate return anyone
else took out in your mind I recall the
story of Marc Dreier an is impersonating
a an attorney I believe extraordinary I
mean story I mean this is Harvard a gal
trained trained attorney smart probably
I'll say one most reflective reflective
and just general I could I can see them
as an academic it just in terms of his
depth self-aware is it well I could say
that's what's interesting self-aware now
when I answer times
step back and think about his actions
not not the time I mean this is the case
of where you know he wanted to build
this world class law firm and didn't
have the money to do to do that and ends
up in but creating a false note on
behalf of one of his billionaire
basically a billionaire client and
what's pretty amazing I think on both
sides both that he was able to create
the first note we're talking tens of
millions of dollars that he was able to
literally create documentation I mean he
didn't have a finance background he was
able to create all the financials from
from scratch
and then some very significant
well-respected hedge funds under
purchasing these notes after the first
one worked he felt the firm might start
taking off but as he said the business
the cost kept going up faster than the
revenues and so you'd another note and
another note it till the point where it
just becomes crazy in that I mean he
ends up finally someone wasn't willing
to take the note just signed an
electronic signature by email someone
was an actual person they're
representing the note and so he has a
personating someone I mean it it gets
really leveled absurdity which I mean I
think he walks into a conference room
pretending to be an attorney for a
pension fund in front of a hedge fund
and someone as I recall actually knows
this pension fund and doesn't recognize
mr. Dreier as an employee any tries
doing I just need to walk out of the
room and calls I mean he hops out and
and this is the point where he actually
is private jet waiting at the airport I
believe is in Toronto he could have
taken off but this is just I think shows
how delusional someone can become and
the lack of self awareness when you're
in a situation it you could say that the
court smart thing would have been to
divert that jet to some country with a
pile of money that was not going to
extradite him right which there are
several people in the book that they did
exactly that but he actually still
thought that could he could get out of
it he could explain his way out of it at
this point in time which it shows how
just crazy um you can get in these
situation other question which is again
coming back to this notion of of what's
the effective deterrent and how do we
minimize or reduce the level of
white-collar crime
you point to sort of these concepts of a
little bit of like public shaming or in
the Orthodox Jewish community there's
sort of individuals who are kind of
shunned by the community and the whole
community is involved in that process
can you describe that and perhaps is
there a way that we can embrace that
concept at least to try and prevent or
deter white collar crime on a broader
scale and that's a great an idea that
but different about how I think what
currently happens is that many times we
see these primary executives face these
significant cases of wrongdoing and and
they don't I mean people backup as
needed also politically so to speak but
they're not genuinely Sean so in that in
a Orthodox Jewish community when someone
engages in something that but against a
rabbinical court and a sanctions placed
upon them they're not able to take
leadership positions at a temple but
what's even more than that people in the
community are told not to not only not
socialize with this person but to not
even visit their place of business
in some sense this this form of shaming
is so deep that it's turning the person
on every dimension not because they're
they're going to be thrown necessarily
in prison I mean this is being dealt
with you could say internally within a
community they're facing prison they're
facing fines they're just they're losing
that their home but what we find that a
lot of cases within the business
community with this this happens is you
don't see that same sense of outrage
occurring within the peers the people
that they're around they're seeking
respect from I mean we see it from
people now Elizabeth Warren when
shilling senator Warren Hall someone in
fronted and and talks about that we see
this in protest when Occupy Wall Street
so we see public and regulatory outrage
in some ways but we don't always see it
from the business community if anything
in some cases we see the letters of
support where people say yeah this is a
this was wrong here but everything else
this person did is so extraordinary and
it's it's pretty remarkable I mean one
thing that is humbling at seeing seeing
individuals when they're being sentenced
is actually seeing with people that are
supporting them which on one hand makes
a lot of sense I mean
these people know them in under
different contexts but the same time you
would expect that you're in this
position of privilege where you're the
head of a major firm you've made
hundreds of millions of dollars
presumably you've actually done a lot of
good stuff in that process if you
haven't figured out how to donate some
money in your worth a couple hundred
million dollars you're you're not a
great person which is very different
than a person you could say that doesn't
have that privilege is being sentenced
you don't get to have the letters of
support attesting to how you donate all
this money how you were able to spend
how you change these communities in and
so the question is I wonder do we need
to have a little bit more of that that
outrage coming from the people in which
they're wined the approval most most
from but that's that's a culture that's
again oh that's a cultural shift now I
think this goes back when it does come
to regulators is to a standpoint that
other people see themselves in that same
boat facing those same kinds of
sanctions let's create challenging
questions you don't want to then support
you want to come support and say it's
not that bad you're kind of protecting
yourself but at the same time that's
that's not the job of the the leader you
should be able to call out in MIT
mistakes when they're made and I think
this is why I think the challenges for
leaders is actually being able to
receive executives of firms and mitting
mistakes but that's generally always
about four steps later right where and I
think in many cases and I like to
believe that people would be both
shareholders the public and regulators
would actually be much more good say
accounting when people when mistakes
happen they happen in major firms I
think two things the other would be kind
of extreme where we can admit those
mistakes upfront and very clearly saying
what we're doing to change those and
it's a degree of transparency which I
don't think you know much like in
political discourse there's a lot of we
present one side externally in one side
internally it may be some of the
discussions that are occurring
internally that are actually significant
what we're doing to address this would
actually go away in terms of great
making people to differently okay well
look we could spend a lot more time on
this it's a fascinating book and
one is a former prosecutor and
enforcement lawyer gave me a perspective
on on individuals that I didn't have in
my former role and so as a personal
thanks to you for having undertaken the
work as well as ending very informative
for all members of the public so